[Music]
hello my name is Eric and I'm a network
specialist here at Google cloud in this
demo we build a data path between vpcs
by configuring each VPC as an NCC spoke
we will use a multi-tier application
architecture to illustrate some key NCC
Concepts a common design practice may
use different vpcs to segment a
multi-tier application Cloud Architects
can use this approach to reduce risk in
one layer of the stack from impacting
the others during changes and updates
and using VPC or projects to segment an
application stack creates a demarcation
that helps the right resources to
quickly isolate and to fix any
issues in the interest of time we've
pre-built some of the network components
that we will be using in the demo by the
end of this we would have configured a
fully mesh data path between all
vpcs the console shows preconfigured
vpcs that NCC will interconnect we'll
create a global route table to store all
VPC subnet routes by creating an NCC Hub
and in this demo I'm naming this new Hub
as NCC
dhub on the same configuration page this
allows me to configure a VPC as a spoke
and this is helpful to me as I will be
configuring VPC one and VPC 4 as NCC
spokes to the NCC Hub when this step is
completed we should see our NCC Hub
routing table be populated with vpc1 and
VPC 4
subnets NCC Hub supports all valid IP V4
ranges except for the privately used
public IP
addresses so far both our VPC Spokes and
our NCC Hub belongs to the same
project network connectivity Center
Center can support other vpcs as spokes
from a different project this allows
other project owners to participate in
the same routing domain all while
maintaining their own administrative
autonomy to demonstrate this we'll
switch to a new gcp project on the NCC
configuration page we configure this
project with the name of our Hub and we
specify the project ID where that Hub
resides and we will name this spoke
cross project spoke and will configure
vpc1 from this new project as an NCC
spoke upon creating new spoke the NCC
help admin will have the opportunity to
review the cross project Spooks request
to join our
Hub the new spoke will only become
active once our NCC Hub admin approves
the
request okay here we've switched back to
the project that's hosting our Hub we
can see the new VPC request once to join
the Hub we drill down into the Hub to
find a new spoke and we can either
accept or reject the requests if we
choose to reject request we can provide
a brief explanation for the rejection
but instead we'll accept and confirm the
activation of the new cross project
spoke once the new cross project spoke
becomes active we should see the subnets
from Cross project vpc1 in the hub's
routing
table
in this next part of the demo we'll see
how NCC checks for overlapping IP ranges
from different
subnets VPC 2 and VPC 3 has both been
preconfigured with an overlapping IP
range of
sl24 we'll watch what happens when we
configure both VPC 2 and VPC 3 as new
spokes to join our hub network
connectivity Center checks for
overlapping submits from all spokes if
it detects an overlap it will fail new
VPC spoke Creation with an
error the error message tells us Subnet
10. 3.3.0 in VPC 3 overlaps with VPC 2
to resolve this error we'll need to
exclude the overlapping 10. 3.3.0 IP
range from both VPC 2 and VPC 3 from
being exported into the NCC Hub routing
table we navigate to the spoke
configuration page like we did before
only this time we enter the overlapping
IP range that will be excluded from
being exported into the hub's routing
table this time the Hub should accept
VPC 2 and VPC 3s Spokes and we can see
the spoke status as active and if we
drill into the NCC hub's routing table
we should only see VPC 2 and VPC 3
subnets that were not
excluded
let's visualize what we've configured so
far we have five vpcs configured as NCC
spokes that is attached to our NCC Hub
our vpcs are preconfigured with firewall
rules that allows traffic between all
subnets in this part of our demo we will
use cloud shell to set up private nap
between
vpcs here I've already logged into Cloud
shell in VPC 2 we create an IP subnet
dedicated for
net next we create the cloud router in
VPC in the same region as our virtual
machine we'll configure the clout router
to translate VPC 2's
overlapping
10332 for subnet finally we'll create a
net rule that will Source net the
overlapping IP range if the traffic
takes an NCC Hub
route logging out of cloudshell and
switching to our web
interface we should see our private net
configuration represented on the
console note that Dynamic Port
allocation is enabled by
default let's test and CC's data path
the web server in vpc1 is configured
with TCP dump to list in for traffic
Source from VPC 4 subnet
10442 we'll use ping to verify the data
path by initiating an echo request from
vm4 and VPC to the web server on vpc1
and if we use the curl command on vm4 to
validate web connectivity to the web
server we should expect to see by
directional traffic between The Two
Hosts
next Let's test our private n kig we'll
log on to pvm that resides on VPC 2's
overlapping subnet on our web server
we'll configure TCP dump to listen for
traffic Source from the net pool range
of 101010
029 note the host IP on
pvm this IP address belongs to the range
that has been excluded from the NCC Hub
route table
when we establish a web request from the
pvm host we should see the web request
come through on the web server using a
translated IP address network
connectivity support for VPC as a spoke
and private VPC is now publicly
available for
testing different tiers of the
application stacked that was once
segmented by VPC and projects can now
use NCC Hub to orchestrate full network
connectivity if you have any questions s
reach out to your friendly neighborhood
Google Cloud customer engineer thanks
for
watching